when we talk about gradient and vertical
sense in 70 we are trying to understand
alright well I can pluck this and draw
it that's nice but I want to go medic
speeches right understanding speeches
would told me a lot more about it so
great well can someone allow you put
your hands up
there's someone give me like a one
sentence explanation of what great it is
okay so the way I calculated it and we
might realize oh by this because we are
going to get there virtually the way
that we calculate Radian is this nice
easy to remember of iterative fracture
okay rise over run that's good we're
gonna refer them a second however it
doesn't tell us what gradient is like
what it means you know what an advance
on them okay so a synonym and a really
hopeful one for Maria is you'll hear
that used interchangeably maybe the same
thing yeah that's really good so I think
all these concepts together and I'm
gonna highlight this one for a second
second they all tell us what really is I
think steepness is maybe the most
helpful one right because it gives you a
picture and it being crossed every day
I'm not going to belabor the point but
it gives you a sense for if something is
steeper we say it has a larger graded
okay so if this was a really steep line
its gradient would have a really high
now and if it was kind of just shallower
that we'd say house up in fact a great
dog like a flat line okay
it's not rising so he states break-ins
now this rise over one business let's
put this onto a diagram you're gonna now
become a fan you should have a Sun grab
on there it doesn't matter too much what
it looks like but the important thing is
to understand take any two points on to
stop that looks like that dis is there
and that's all Paul Ryan's how far we
ascended versus how about horizontally
did it take for us to go that far up so
this is the horizontal distance that
corresponds to it that's what it really
is convenient so rise everyone it's a
fraction okay you can see like I
mentioned if you don't rise anywhere
just a flat line rise will be zero so
then it doesn't matter what one is zero
over anything will still be zero right
a grade of zero which means this little
rowdy a great you zero means it's a
languages what's just flat right I guess
the technical word roommate it's
horizontal
it's a great easier it means flying
across horizontally
what would a gradient of one look like
if I said rise over run don't write this
part down so you can see why don't be
cute if I surprised if over run it was
equal to one what would that mean about
the relationship between rise here
they're the same right and if you pull
back your algebra skills you can see I
can just multiply both sides by this
denominator I can see it I'm gonna get
this yes I thought so
a grade of one would look like and if
you can pad this and if I go to that
take whatever distance your bun is just
have a look at what it your diagram
looks like take that and measure the
same distance that Y is the same so my
diagram that looks something like yes
okay now I'm hoping that you all have
diagrams that look a little bit
different to the person next to you but
the import of the origin notices have a
look at this wise one triangle you just
made rise here if you look at the
triangle the person next to you as well
there might be different sizes but
they're all going to look very similar
to each other do you notice that in fact
because this side is the same this side
we give this triangle special name two
sides of the same starts with an i it's
our saucily right we've made an
isosceles triangle this side is the same
and
son what's this angle look like to you
this is right excite this is a right
angle Internet so if this is a right
angle
okay we're killing it today right it's
an isosceles triangle so these other two
English over here have to be the same as
well right sides of the same thing
that's 90 what those chieng who's going
to be they both can 25 so we can add
this underneath oh you centigrade easier
means a horizontal plane a grain of one
means online that's 45 degrees from the
horizontal for T 5 teachers the
technique what is an inclination you
might remember from Los Angles of
information like elevation depression
that type of thing 45 degrees that's
pretty steep but this is what we mean by
grading of one just so you have a
picture just for a second ago the
diagram you've gone from yes what how
about look at my diagram from it have a
look at the original black and blue
training that I drew it clearly has a
gradient was pretty bad but here's a
grade that's less than 1 do you see that
it's not as steep like the green light
is speak on yes so this rating cute it's
like it's less than 1 but it's more than
0 it's gonna be a fraction of some kind
do you agree so I just want you to get a
picture like a physical sense for when
you get different numbers what does that
mean in your head what if you had a
greening of two it'd be really steep
right come in it's gonna air it twice as
high for the same run
Komachi
did you just see that that was the guy
that go away
yes I said you really want you just want
to make a point term let's go ahead and
finish this concept so you guys can get
started I don't finish my conversation
this is your brain right again I think
the key concept of so GLaDOS mission is
its thickness like how steep is
something we just finished by saying
about a gradient to it means that this
man is right I'm going twice as hard I
don't want to have to want that okay
it's a very very steep thing what that
corresponds to is can you turn back a
page or maybe it's even on the page
you've got at the moment we're gonna
look at our agents do you remember that
now the gradient the steepness of that
line in fact I want you to do more than
that I want you to calculate it the way
we calculated it right go back have a
look at for example you've got a whole
bunch of spots where they have one
distance apart right like what two is
going to be rise over run so pick any
two points right if you might do it the
way we did it pick weekend and hit the
start work out what okay in that space
how far is it visible versus how far is
it what now just quickly go and do that
you've got all of the numbers there
right if I recall we went up like six
kilos or something like you know six
years so that's this horizontal it's the
isn't the dependent or independent
number kilos it's an independent
independent sure that represents run
over six what's the highest value that I
got what number now you would even call
in this point twenty five dollars based
on the 21
sorry that's okay we're in the right
court on this expansive garden okay now
just quickly you have a look at this
right 21 divided by six
what is this number this number should
be familiar it's definitely three it's
three point five right three all 50 what
if it says that number huh
that's how much they cost but that's the
cost well we are so this connection here
is no I'm trying to draw out to you
right the Grady is more than just like
oh how much is it it's actually telling
you something meaningful about the
Donovan
now we're not surprised by this because
this is f studies way like the first
sentence says oranges are sold for $3
per kilo right beginning like that but
questions were often not like how task
will be to find out what's going on to
get to the bottom of it what is the cost
of what's the population of housing or
whatever so that's what grading is I'm
really briefly and there's not much to
say really about it can I describe this
because I think it's almost on the
diagram very good right we're talking
about this intercept is intercept me
everything's cut or meet right which is
why when you're in touch football and
you pass and someone intercept the ball
it's cuz they're in the board same place
and same time so the vertical intercept
over here another color there is this
spot over here it's where our graph I've
got back up here it's where the graph
intersects with the vertical axis so
this is the vertical intercept
now if you recall back to court and
remarried loves to you or maybe she
don't remember that's okay we used to
call these X&Y
like we frequently call them x and y
right since the vertical one is so often
called why we often call this the
y-intercept I hope that phrase like sort
of rings a bell right it's not always
why about it might be cost it might be
time it might be kilometers but the
important thing is it's the intercept on
this the dependent variable